um yeah thanks for inviting me to this
workshop i was really really hoping to
be there in person but then there was a
covert case in my daughter's daycare and
i had to cancel all my plans
so unfortunately i'll be remote for this
week but uh i do still want to tell you
about this topic which i hope can be
an interesting kind of
probabilistic substrate for building
causal models and doing causal inference
and so the topic of my talk is is
tractable probabilistic circuits um by
the way i don't really know in this
setup if it's easy to interrupt with
questions but if it is please feel free
to do so um yeah okay
all right so uh what do i know what do i
want to talk about so uh first of all
what are these tractable prosthetic
circuits you probably haven't really
seen them before
then i want to convince you very briefly
just from a machine learning perspective
that these models are quite interesting
and very powerful but of course this is
not a machine learning workshop and i
mostly want to talk about the
theoretical properties of these things
in what is their expressive power
circuit lower bounds and how far can we
push tractable inference and so those
would be the algorithmic aspects of
these representations
okay so first of all what are these
tractable prostatic circuits so here's a
little bit of an alphabet soup of
different generative models probably
stick models that are around
very famously things like gans
variational autoencoders more
traditional things like beta networks
vector graphs etc and it's a little bit
of an alphabet soup and so the way that
i like to
distinguish these different things is in
terms of tractable versus intractable
models
the tractable models are relatively
simple kind of models but they can be
very powerful but their their their
simplicity allows you to compute uh for
example a marginal probability a
partition function exactly in polynomial
time often in linear time in the size of
the representation
and then you have the intractable models
where often the only thing you can
really do is sample from the model
um and so there's a lot of tractable
models it's kind of impossible to really
have the overview of the whole
literature
some product networks and junction trees
dpps arithmetic circuits in the
uai
community etc etc
and so what i would like to
kind of summarize for you is that
essentially all of these tractable
models that allow you to compute a
marginal probability a partition
function they can really just be
understood
as being very simple computational
graphs
and so we refer to kind of this whole
family of tractable models as
probabilistic circuits
so this is what they look like they are
very similar to neural networks in that
they form a computation graph they're
also very similar to arithmetic circuits
in the theory community
at the inputs you have some simple
distribution let's say a univariate
gaussian bernoulli or really anything
you want something really simple that
allows you to compute what you want
efficiently let's say a marginal
probability
then the one building block is mixture
models uh some nodes so these some units
they take two other circuits as input
and take a weighted average that's your
standard mixture model and then there is
a very basic notion of factorization you
take two
pro six circuits that are over different
uh random variables and you multiply
them to get the product distribution
and then you make a little bit of an
inductive leap and you just construct
directed acyclic graphs with these types
of
computational units and then of course
you can really think of them as neural
networks having millions hundreds of
millions of these computational units
okay
uh why do we call them tractable models
well they're tractable because we can
compute a whole bunch of things exactly
and efficiently the simplest thing you
would like to compute is the the
likelihood function we would like to
know the probability of some feature
vector over here
and um
the probability of this vector here so
what we do is we ask all of the the
inputs to our probability circuit what
is the likelihood of all of the data
you get those numbers these are the
likelihoods densities are probabilities
it doesn't matter
and then you just sum them multiply them
and in the end you get that the
likelihood of the model given this data
point is 0.75 okay so very simple feed
forward evaluation
but what we really want to do is compute
things that are more challenging like
marginals right and so these are
traditionally uh interactable and
graphical models and really almost
anything you can think of
um so here we'll have to invoke some
really basic properties they're very
natural
but they're required if you would like
to compute a marginal probability
the first property is called smoothness
and it really means that when you have a
mixture model it doesn't make sense to
mix two distributions that have
disjoined uh scopes disjoined sets of
random variables if you mix the two
distributions together they must be
talking about the exact same set of
random variables otherwise a mixture
model is still defined
so that's the property of smoothness
and then more interesting is the
property of decomposability
decomposability says that when you take
a product distribution the
component distributions have to be
independent uh from each other they must
have a disjoint scope
and of course this makes sense you know
products you can only take over
probabilities that are different random
variables um this property is also very
natural from a theoretical perspective
right in the arithmetic circuit
literature this is called syntactic
multilinearity
and with these two properties now you
can compute a margin
and here's how you do it uh you can just
think of it as a as a recursive kind of
way of simplifying an integral right if
i need to compute an integral over a sum
note
you know because of linearity
i can just take the weighted average of
the integrals of the children okay so
that's pretty straightforward
if i have a product
note here and i need to compute some
integral because of this decomposability
i can really just take the product of
the integrals over the three different
children all restricted to the scope
that they are talking about okay so all
these integrals they just decompose into
easier ones and i can compute my
integral in this kind of top-down
recursive manner
and this gives you a very nice dynamic
programming algorithm where if i now
want to compute some marginal
probability of x2 and x4 having some
value marginalizing out x1 and x3
what i do is well i i would have to
compute the integral over x1 and x3 and
that ends up being 1 in a distribution
so all of the input nodes that are
marginalized out become one
all the other ones they evaluate to
their likelihoods and then what i do is
i take sums of products of sums of
products and i get my marginal
probability functions
hope this makes sense otherwise again
feel free to interrupt somehow i'm not
sure how at all here but i i hope to
hear someone ask a question
anyway
okay
um so this is why these models are
tractable why we're interested in them
um so the next question is well you know
if i can compute a marginal probability
then surely these probabilistic models
are very simple maybe they're like naive
bayes they're they're kind of uh
you know they have a limited capacity
they're really just too simple to really
fit a interesting data set right so that
would be your immediate gut feeling and
so the next
couple of minutes i just want to argue
that yeah this is this is not the case
these are actually quite powerful models
because they can really have the power
of a deep neural network in the sense
that they can
have a gigantic number of neurons and
really fit data very well
um so here's a quick
summary of how one could learn such a
pro sticker circuit um so the first
question is where you actually get the
structure from you need to have this
smoothness and decomposability uh it's
not as straightforward as just you know
adding a few layers to your neural
network um so you have to do a little
bit of extra work and this is how we do
it um this is a model that we call
hidden challengers
we start from our mutual information
matrix between all of the random
variables estimated on the data from
this we just do the standard you know 70
year old learning of childhood trees
right you learn a three-shaped graphical
model that best fits uh this data
and then we turn it into a
hidden variable model and so this is
crucial to increase the capacity of
these charu trees so now we take exactly
the same structure that we learned
before but we
we turn all of these variables that were
the pixels in our image into latent
variables and all of the pixels of our
image are now just emitted from these
latent variables very very similar to
how you take a
markov chain and turn it into a hidden
markov model
so this is still a graphical model right
so this is uh you know old school
uh so how do we turn it into a neural
network well if you do inference on this
graphical model you're going to do a
bunch of sums and products you know your
favorite inference algorithm uh on this
on this three shape graphical model
message passing it's essentially doing
sums of products of sums of products you
can turn this into an equivalent
probabilistic circuit and now you have a
neural network
and now that you have this neural
network you can just train it i'm using
mini batch stochastic expectation
maximizer you just drain it like a
neural network okay and that means you
can really scale that up on the gpu to
to to 100 million parameters
okay so that's one way to learn these
models um here's a quick
uh summary of
uh you know trying to convince you that
this is this is really a powerful tool
um so here we look at an application
which is image compression
um
i'm sure you're familiar with the basic
concept right you encode the data in a
bit stream and you decode it and of
course if you have a probabilistic model
to do the encoding uh you can do entropy
coding or you can for example do
arithmetic coding to really just get the
the lowest number of bits here to
represent your image to compress it
maximally
so this in general if you if you use a
machine learning model to do this this
is called neural compression
and so what we're doing here is using a
probabilistic circuit to compress mnist
images
and so the first thing that should
surprise you is that if you just train
this model that i showed on the previous
slide
um it's really expressive
and it actually gets a state-of-the-art
likelihood on mnist so it outperforms
the variational auto encoders
hierarchical variation of the flow
models it outperforms really anything
else that i'm aware of in uh fitting a
density to uh missed pixels and this is
the the full endless right so no no
binarization no quantization just for
limbs
um and then what's also really
interesting is that if you want to do
compression it has to be fast right you
cannot really afford uh to spend like a
minute
decompressing your image and so this is
really tricky if you have a powerful pro
stick model you need to compute a lot of
marginal probabilities to do arithmetic
coding to do your image compression and
decompression
essentially you have to compute what is
the probability of the next pixel uh
values uh the cumulative probability
given all the previously sent pixels
right so that's a lot of different
modules you have to compute all in
sequence
and so
what's what's in general true about
these probabilistic circuits is that
they're so well behaved that typically
these things end up having some nice
algorithmic solution and here the
summary is that instead of having to
compute this
marginal query for each pixel you know
linear in the dimension of the image you
can actually just have this logarithmic
factor because a lot of the computation
can be amortized
and the summary is then that you get
state of the art compression rates on
mnist em nist close to state of the art
on fashion mist etc compared to all of
these baselines
but you also get this you know five to
forty times faster than neural network
methods
okay so this was kind of a whirlwind
tour you can also combine promising
circuits with bijections flow models and
also get really good results in imagenet
density estimation
all right so this was a kind of a
whirlwind tour of like the machine
learning side of things so the first the
basic representation then you know the
machine learning side of things uh you
know hopefully now you're convinced that
okay these models might be worth of some
more theoretical study because they do
seem to have some
capabilities right
and so here's where i
want to get into the the theory of you
know what can these models represent
and also uh
how far can we push this tractable
inference i told you we can compute
marginal probabilities likelihoods but
there's so many more questions you could
have of probability distribution and you
know what what do we need from these
models in order to compute things like a
kl divergence exactly and in polynomial
time
okay so first question first um
well you know these probabilistic
circuits they
they kind of can do any some product
computation right so if you have your uh
junction tree algorithm your
kind of message passing on trees you
have your some product networks etc
they're all really just doing the same
computation
and so the natural question is you know
do we know of any probabilistic models
that are tractable that we can compute a
marginal probability for yet that are
not captured by this probabilistic
circuit computation for us
and so here
there was a few years ago there was just
this one model that
kept bugging me because it is a
tractable model called determinal point
processes
and
we didn't know how it related to
probably six circuits and so briefly at
the detrimental point process it's
really just this matrix
where if you would like to compute a
probability for a particular
world
for example i would like to know the
probability that x1 is true x 3 is true
everything else is false then i just
take the sub the subdeterminant of the
the first and third row and column
okay so the the red numbers here they're
determinant up to a
normalizing constant is the probability
of this particular world
and so of course this determinant is
efficient to compute and so this is a
tractable probabilistic model
these are really nice they're tractable
for lackluster marginals they capture
global negative dependence in an elegant
way and they're of course used a lot for
capturing diversity in recommender
systems
and so the question here is well you
have these probabilistic circuits that
actually include all graphical models
that are able to do exact inference and
on the other hand we have determinable
point processes how are they related
and uh one part of the answer is really
easy
uh
you know there are models there are
distributions that live at the
intersection of the two of them for
example if your determinable point
process is a diagonal matrix
fully factorized distribution it also
has a probabilistic circuit
representation
but the real question is are there
determinable point processes that cannot
be captured in this captured in this
framework that i just uh showed you
okay um
and so we started looking first at you
know what is what's the easiest theorem
to prove is well you take the type of
probable stick circuit i mean it's a
whole family of different models you
take the type of prosic circuit that is
the
most
restricted one in its properties but
also the most tractable one that you can
compute more than just marginal switch
these are called these are called pro
six sentential decision diagrams and so
it's pretty easy to prove that yeah with
probability one a random dpp is not
going to be having a tractable
representation as a psd
and then we start kind of dropping some
of these properties
if it's just a syntactic multi-linear pc
with positive parameters no impossible
if you have
you know other properties i won't go
into details no impossible uh some
product networks perhaps the most famous
type of pro-stick circuit also they
cannot represent certain dpps
efficiently and um if you have syntactic
multi-linear pro-stick circuits so
decomposable pcs with negative
parameters then the question is open
right so we can add this to the open
question session tomorrow although it's
really just as hard as proving
uh you know circuit lower bounds with
negative
yeah so so it's essentially a very
difficult problem for the whole theory
community so i don't really think this
is one we can easily solve
okay so the summary here is that yeah
these properties theoretically they do
actually uh limit what you can represent
and specifically uh dpps are the type of
model that you cannot easily represent
uh in these promoting circuits
so what we then try to do next is uh
come up with some representation that
kind of unifies uh the promo 6 circuits
that we knew with this determinant point
process model and this is tricky right
because the promising circuits are
computation graphs dpps are kind of
determinant based kind of
you know matrix matrix based models they
don't really speak the same language
until we realize that yeah there is one
language that is in common between all
of these things and it's in fact the
language that a lot of theoreticians use
to study probability
right and so that's the language of
probability generating functions
um
if you're not familiar with these
i mean i'm sure more you know most of
the audience is a bigger expert on these
than i am
essentially what they are
there are these polynomials that
kind of capture the probability of a
possible world as coefficients of these
terms here
specifically this term here where the
the z appears
all of the z's appear corresponds to the
world where all of these features are
set to true it has a 16
probability okay
and um
now of course these probability
generating functions are often used to
prove theorems right they're a
theoretical tool i i'm not aware of them
really being used as a machine learning
model per se
right
and so the little bit of a leap that we
made was to say well let's take these
generating functions which you know if
they're just flat functions they have
as many terms as there are
you know possible worlds right these are
just theoretical tools and let's really
think of them as data structures as
little directed acyclic graphs right i
can take this generating function i can
rewrite it in this form and it's still
the same probability distribution
so then it's not much of a leap to say
well if we can if we can do this why
don't we just write them as computation
graphs as
something that looks similar to a
probabilistic circuit
so this is really just the same as a
probabilistic circuit the only
difference is that at the inputs now we
have constants and we also have these
these variables here that come from the
generating function
syntax
otherwise this is just representing
exactly the same generating function we
had before but just more compactly as a
circuit
uh i guess you can see how yeah all of
the terms here show up in the circuit
so now we have some kind of common
language perhaps between the two because
it's very well known that a detrimental
point process also has a generating
function and it is described in this way
it's really up to a constant a
determinant of this matrix here
which is the the matrix l the parameters
i showed you earlier
we had to take these sub determinants
here and then this diagonal matrix of
these these z's here
um this determinant has a arithmetic
circuit uh you can find some
theory papers that show how to construct
it and so bottom line is you can now
take these dpps and you can turn them
into these probabilistic generating
functions represented as circuits so
purposely generating circuits
of polynomial size
and so that means that now we have a
representation that captures dpps and
similarly you can take a probabilistic
circuit and you can write it in this pgc
syntax
but we're not done yet right the whole
point of probabilising circuits is that
we have a representation that allows for
tractable inference for example margins
so how is it possible that if you give
me a gigantic probabilistic
generating function as a circuit with
100 million nodes that i can even
compute a marginal probability there
right it's not obvious i mean clearly
the the generating function represents
the right distribution
but how is it even possible to compute a
marginal probability so let me
illustrate how this works um let's say i
want to compute the probability that x1
is 1x2 is 0
etc etc so the way that we'll evaluate
the circuit to compute a marginal is
that whenever the variable is observed
to be one we replace it by some symbolic
t
okay
if it's
set to zero we replace it by zero and
otherwise we replace it by one and so
now through the magic of generating
functions what this really means is that
we are now computing
this other polynomial here it's a
polynomial in t
um
and its degree is up to the number of
random variables
and the probability that we're looking
for
of the
the world corresponding to these inputs
is just the leading coefficient of this
polynomial
okay
let me give you just a simple example of
how this works right so i want to
compute specifically this input
this marginal probability so i input 0 1
and this symbolic t
depending on
the query i have i evaluate my
polynomial it's point 16 t plus blah and
indeed the point 16 is the probability
of these two worlds which is the if you
sum them up is the probability of this
margin okay and so this can all be done
in time polynomial in this size of the
circuit
okay um if you're a machine learner in
the audience and you're like oh this is
a little theory or you know almost
theory i care about my bottom line
machine learning performance if you now
take the standard data sets that people
use to train determinant point processes
and you train
this generating function model
which you can now kind of make up some
architecture for it it suddenly has much
more flexibility than just the dpp
and then you get state-of-the-art
likelihoods on 11 of the 15 standard
data sets used in this field so this
also works well as a machine learning
model
okay so that was kind of my brief intro
on like what is the
what's the
circuit lower bound kind of
representation power
property of these uh of these models and
then for the remainder of my talk i want
to kind of briefly go over some
interesting algorithmic aspects of query
evaluation on these models
um specifically you know can we compute
something more difficult than just a
marginal probability
okay so now we're going back to uh the
probabilistic circuit world and uh we
would like to compute things like kl
divergence because obviously this would
be super useful for example
if i want to do variational inference
but you know in many domains you would
like to compute a cal divergence
this is the definition um
and the approach we will take is as
always as through you know what we've
done throughout this talk is just treat
these problems as computation graphs so
now i can really just think of this
scale divergence as being this pipeline
where first i have to take this quotient
of two distributions p and q
okay
then for the result of that quotient i
have to take the log of this function
uh you know element wise right then i
have to take the element-wise product
with the distribution p
and then i have to compute an integral
and so far the only thing that i told
you how to do is compute this integral
right computing this integral was
computing the marginal probability in
this case it's not necessarily a
probability but the same algorithm
applies you can compute an integral on
these uh these circuit representations
that are
decomposable and smooth
but how do we figure out whether we can
take these quotients the log and the
products
and moreover if we can do so then
there's a whole bunch of other stuff we
can compute like cross entropy etc etc
that are really just the same building
blocks over and over again
and so here without going into too many
details uh what we proved is that
if your input
distribution is smooth and decomposable
which are the properties i already
showed you before but it has this other
property called determinism um
you know you might know this as an
ambiguity in the theory world etcetera
etcetera it basically means that when
you have a mixture model the mixture
components are
in their support
if you have this property then yes you
can take efficiently the log of this
distribution and get this new circuit
which is no longer a distribution of
course it's just it's just a function
but it's still smooth and decomposable
and therefore we can still compute an
integral here
and again without boring you with all
the details you can do this exercise for
a lot of these operations for products
powers quotients logs exponents
and what we did here is find the
properties that are required of the
inputs in order to get nice properties
of the output what do we need on the
inputs so that on the output we can
still compute let's say an integral
and then we also prove that when you
don't have these properties essentially
it's impossible to
to do these operations on the
distribution
so these were kind of the basic building
blocks of how you combine circuits and
now you can really have fun finding in
your textbooks your favorite uh
questions you know can i compute across
entropy can i compute a kl divergence
etc etc
then you know the properties necessary
to do all of these arithmetic operations
and then we also prove that if you don't
have those properties things are
computationally hard
um okay so this is
kind of a quick
uh
way to hopefully entice you to look into
these information theoretical queries on
distribution and you know think when can
we actually compute them when are they
tractable because you know now everyone
just assumes that you'll have to sample
your way through these types of problems
another very difficult question is how
to do marginal math so in marginal map
the goal is uh to
find the most likely state of a subset
of your random variables
uh while marginalizing out a uh other
set of variables uh and then also maybe
observing
for a third set of variables their value
this is essentially what you want to do
if you let's say
generate a text from a language model if
you want to do
you know labeling of pixels in an image
in a latent variable model et cetera
this is really the task that a lot of
machine learning
downstream is about
unfortunately it's a really difficult
task computationally
it's np to the pp complete for graphical
models it's np hard still on tractable
graphical models like
nice base models
so so this is a tricky problem and so
here maybe we don't really hope to find
a tractable representation that you can
compute any kind of marginal map query
on that seems like a bit of a stretch
but we can still use the tractability of
these models to actually come up with
interesting algorithms and so one such
interesting algorithm is the one here
and the observation is that if you try
to do these optimization tasks on
distributions like marginal map then
really a large part of your model
becomes irrelevant to the computation
you need to do
for example
if i am interested in states that look
like this
then this part of my circuit is
irrelevant the the other part is
completely irrelevant whatever the
parameters are here it doesn't really it
doesn't really change what would be the
marginal map
so the goal here is to really find which
part of my model is actually relevant to
to the query and then simplify the model
and again without going into too much
details this gives you a
state-of-the-art algorithm for marginal
map on promising circuits and uh
graphical models that are turned into
prostate circuits
okay
final
uh kind of interesting connection is to
uh
kernels uh which i hope will be of
interest to some folks in the audience
some of the theoreticians
so a lot of applications of kernels
involve computing and expectation
over
two distributions to data distributions
of the kernel
and so again the standard trick you do
is you know when you build these
algorithms around uh probabilistic
circuits and other circuits you just
think of any computation as being a
circuit based computation and so also
here we now take our uh our favorite
kernel and then we just turn it into a
little computation graph sums of
products of these very simple univariate
input units
and what we show is that
with smooth and decomposable processing
circuits
we can also compute this expectation in
polynomial time
of these types of kernels
and so this then allows you to do some
really cool applications for example if
you have a support vector regression
model that looks like this
where you use the kernel
essentially as a regression model
you can now actually impute over missing
features in your predictions using a
probabilistic circuit and compute the
expectation of your support vector
regression model
expectation over all of the imputations
of your missing features and so this is
not something you can do standardly with
support vector regression
similarly if you're into stein
variational inference or the stein
operator
it also involves an expected kernel
matrix where you can actually
do some of this stuff
exactly in closed form using not just
samples but using circuits to compute
expectations of these kernels
all right so that was the
the big overview so i hope that i at
least got across kind of what are these
probabilistic circuits
um
uh as you know their simple syntax and
how you compute a marginal um i hope i
convinced you that these are actually
really good machine learning models even
though this is not a machine learning
workshop
but then that there's interesting
connections to the theory community
specifically to the
arithmetic circuit and specifically
specifically the multilinear arithmetic
circuit lower bound community
but then also that there's interesting
new algorithms that one can derive by
looking at distributions and functions
really as computation graphs and doing
operations on them assuming properties
all right thanks for your attention and
also thanks for all the folks who did
the actual work on this
for
did you hear us okay yeah i can hear you
yeah question yeah
actually
can you hear me
yeah oh yeah so far the image data you
suggest combining the model with a
normalizing flow so how does it compare
to just training a normalizing flow by
itself like are there advantages of this
versus just using a normalizing flow
yeah good question so let me quickly
find the slide so we actually compared
to the normalizing flow directly and
so
this is too far
sorry
[Music]
oh so this is the slide you're asking
about
so here idf is uh is a normalizing flow
discrete normalizing flow model and so
the essentially what we did is so
normalizing flows similar to the aes
they have a latent space which is
actually a very very simple tractable
model like a fully factorized gaussian
or a fully factorized distribution
or complete product distribution right
and so what we did here is we took idf
and we replaced that very simple latent
space by a non-trivial probabilistic
circuit in the latent space and this is
pc plus idf and
the summary here is that yeah if you
actually use a
very expressive tractable model as your
latent space you get a significant boost
in these flow models and
yeah and so this is a direct comparison
of the flow model uh two two flow models
with a simple
latent space and with a pro six circuit
plate in space does that answer your
question
yeah
but it doesn't have the like you can't
compute marginals or anything right yeah
so that's a good point so in this pc
plus idf model you cannot compute a
marginal because the bijection of the
flow model actually ruins that ability
but it turns out that if you want to do
image compression you don't really need
the ability to compute the marginals
here you just need to get uh because the
you know you can essentially compute the
marginal in the latent space through the
bijection and that's enough to do image
compression
if you want to compute marginals in
pixel space then here you're out of luck
so so here we're kind of
walking a fine line of tractability
where we still
are tractable enough to do image
compression but we do lose some of the
power and in exchange we get
state-of-the-art or maybe not
state-of-the-art really good uh image
compression and likelihood
questions
oh so i have one um
uh do you know of any could so you you
said that matt in
was hard under these
models um are there any kind of
conditions under which like approximate
map inference could be
possible
yeah that's a good question there might
be and i'm not aware of them but i i'm
not aware of any um
so so there
there is a condition in which certain
types of map inferences are possible so
if you have a certain order on your
variables and you restrict yourself to
map
problems that are
uh you know always the same set of
optimization variables and the same set
of marginal variables then then there is
a tractable model for it which is
essentially a prop66 circuit with a
particular variable order
but that's that's really not a real
solution because essentially uh you know
you're restricted to just essentially
one query you have a tractable model for
one specific query and it's not really a
general solution in terms of
guarantees
approximation guarantees uh i would love
to know if anyone knew about a model
that had those
yeah i don't know oh i'll i'll say the
reason why i ask is about
um
the dpps
i think there there's some sub
modularity
and so you can do approximate map
inference on those which is what made me
think about that oh yeah good point so
so this is for full what we call full
map so that there we we find the most
likely state of all of the variables and
then yes you you have the approximation
guarantee so this is marginal map right
and
but i guess in dpps i would also have
the same approximation guarantee yeah
i'll have to think about that one
uh
yeah it's not obvious to me that
marginal map is also has guarantees on
dpps but yeah we can talk about this
offline maybe that's interesting
is it clear what the distinction is
between marginal map and map right so
the map it's really
yeah okay oh yes yes and by the way i
we can talk offline more about it but i
think marginal map is possible for dvd
but we can talk that's my intuition i
think because the dpp is closed under
yeah anyways
sounds good
in thanks we are exactly on time for our
break the next part will begin at 10 40.
that's a good